احمد البلوشي اول امراه اماراتيه تسلقت
اعلى قمه في العالم
اتصلت مطار اول شيء وثاني يوم قمت وجهزت
اغراضي واشتريت الاشياء اللي كانت ناقصه
واليوم اللي بعده اخذت الطياره داخليه
لمطار لوكلا اذا وصلنا هناك شوي متاخر لان
الطياره اتاخرت واليوم الثاني طبعا كله
خاص مشي على الارجل من قريه القريه
[موسيقى]
لين ما وصلنا للمخيم الرئيسي وهذا اخذ
خمسه ايام او خمسه ايام
لما وصلت المخيم الرئيسي قعدت هناك تقريبا
خمسه ايام بعدين تحركت للمخيم الاول بس
كان المجال مفتوح يعني للقمه فانا قررت
اني اكمل يعني ما ارجع وصلت لاني وصلت
للمخيم الثاني وقعدت خمسه ايام وطبعا تحت
مراقبه يعني من الستاف
كنت بخير ومكان فيني اي اعراض مرض
الارتفاعات
بعد خمسه ايام تقريبا او ست ايام طلعت
للمخيم الثالث ورجعت مره ثانيه عشان
يشوفوني اذا الجسم مهيئ ولا لا بعدين طلعت
المخيم الثالث والرابع
تحديات اللي واجهتني اثناء الرحله الجو
كان جدا بارد الضغط الارتفاع يعني تغير
الاكل والنظام الرقاد وهالاشياء يعني اول
ما وصلت القمه حسيت بالفخر
وبالانجاز اني قدرت احقق الهدف اللي انا
كنت رايحه عشان عشانه طبعا اني ارفع علم
من دوله الامارات كاول امراه اماراتيه
شعور ما اقدر اوصفه الرساله اللي ابغي
اوجهها لكل امراه اماراتيه انه اذا عندك
هدف تقدرين تحققينه بالاستمراريه
والمثابره
ومواجهه التحديات